avis ho chineur la boutique de
l'association Les Ateliers du kiosque
solidaire a ouvert ses portes à Buc en
décembre 2021 livre vaisselle jouet ou
encore textile les habitants peuvent
venir donner les articles dont il ne se
servent plus ils seront ensuite proposés
à des prises solidaires généralement
divisées par 3 ou 4 comparés au tarif
d'origine pendant le confinement les
gens se sont mis à beaucoup beaucoup
triés et jetés décédés de trouver un une
solution à la gestion des encombrants
dans cette résidence ou dans une autre
résidence donc j'en ai parlé au bailleur
social
qui m'a mise en relation avec la peste
qui est une structure qui accompagne les
créateurs de projet suite à sa demande
Maria obtient ce local de 60 mètres
carrés son objectif évité à des objets
souvent en bon état de se retrouver
inutilement à la poubelle en outre faire
de ce lieu un endroit convivial pour
créer du lien social c'est pas une
occupation c'est quelque chose qui
permet de faire avancer les choses au
niveau humain au niveau social au niveau
même de tout ce qui est la nature aussi
puisque si on jette pas et qu'on peut
faire autre chose avec
tout le monde dit tout le monde y gagne
en fait une dizaine de bénévoles aide au
tri au nettoyage et à la valorisation
des dons reçus des objets uniques pour
le plus grand plaisir des chineur nous y
trouvons des jeux pour les enfants ça
les occupe le mercredi déjà il choisit
ce même ce qu'ils veulent c'est beaucoup
moins cher et ça permet de faire un
petit un petit cadeau j'ai profité du
week-end pour faire du tri et pour
revaloriser les objets dont je me
servais plus c'est bien d'aider les
autres et comme on peut avoir besoin
d'aide à n'importe quel moment de notre
vie en fait si vous souhaitez dénicher
ces objets de seconde main la boutique
est ouverte à tous les mercredis jeudi
et samedi de 14h à 18h